Hello there, my children.
It’s me, SCP-343, but you probably know
me better as God.
It’s been strange lately, hasn’t it?
To the untrained eye, it seems like things
are only getting crazier out there.
Nothing seems certain or safe anymore.
So naturally, you’ve got questions for me.
It makes sense, in your position I’d probably
do the same thing.
So let’s see what burning queries are on
your mind, and of course, I’ll do my best
to answer them.
Indigo Wolf said, “I’d ask him for instructions:
“What’s the best way to raise SCP-999
to be ready for the Scarlet King?”
So we’d be fully prepared for his arrival.”
Ah, the Scarlet King, he’s a nasty customer.
I try to avoid associating with him when I
can.
His vibes are atrocious, and he certainly
has some unpleasant plans for everything I’ve
created if ever he gets his way.
But to answer your question about how best
to raise SCP-999.
To me, the answer is obvious: With love.
The Scarlet King is the master of malice and
savagery, and therefore, malice and savagery
cannot be used as tools against him.
Only the light of love can burn out the hate
hiding in the dark.
Tyron Morgan said, “I’d ask, Why does
he choose to be at an SCP Foundation site
rather than in the world helping people?”
There are many ways to help, and not all of
them mean getting involved directly.
A set of training wheels can help someone
ride a bike, but they will never truly know
how to ride until the training wheels are
removed.
What’s that saying you came up with?
The Lord helps those who help themselves.
Clockworksnowman said, “I would ask him
something about how he said "it's not one
of mine" when asked about 682 and then WHO
did make it).”
There are certain details I’d rather not
get into when discussing that...thing, but
all I can tell you is, whoever made it didn’t
make it with love.
Beasts like that are perversions of the gift
of creation.
It doesn’t even enjoy its own life.
Is that any way to exist?
We must pity it if anything.
Noct_28 Hi said, “I guess an interesting
question would be “What do you think of
Atheists?”
Depends on the atheist.
I’ve known Angelic Atheists and Monstrous
Believers, and of course, vice versa.
What matters most in life is that you’re
a good person - that you’re kind and understanding
to your fellow human beings, and you leave
the world a little better than you found it.
Even if you don’t believe in me, if you’re
a good person, I’ll believe in you.
Chase Crowe said, “Are there any regrets
that you have, in terms of what your creation
has become?”
Regret.
It’s an interesting word.
The Greek playwright Agathon once said, “Only
this is denied even to God, The power to make
what has been done undone.”
I regret nothing of my past because the past
is beyond all of us.
For what it’s worth, I’m proud of all
of you.
Irish Spartan Studios said, “I'd ask him:
"When will the 'Surviving Infinite Ikea' video
come out?"
It already has, my son.
You see?
Patience is a virtue.
Max’s Intense Videos said, “Is there a
way to terminate the immortal lizard or at
the very least make him not want to kill every
living thing?”
I’ve gone on record saying this before,
but that thing isn’t one of mine.
The SCP Foundation will have to figure out
that nasty piece of work by themselves.
Dr. Veronica said, “I'd ask him "What's
the name of the SCP doctor we see in all these
videos with black hair, a black beard, and
glasses?
He's the one presenting anomalies to us more
than anybody else, so he must be important."
He’s a charming fellow.
We hang out every Wednesday and watch episodes
of Ru Paul’s Drag Race on Netflix.
I won’t share his name here out of respect
for his privacy, but rest assured, you’re
in good hands with him.
Brandon Kaminari said, "Considering the Foundation's
tendencies and devotion to their cause, other
than the times you felt a Divine Duty to Intervene,
have you ever tried to convince the Foundation
to cure something or someone, offer to completely
destroy an item, or even make their work easier?"
Frankly, that isn’t my place.
The problem with ultimate power is that it
means you can’t really choose sides.
To put my finger on the scale could lead to
catastrophic effects, and if I save one person
or even a handful of people, that means I’d
need to save everyone all the time.
And if I’m always saving everyone, you no
longer have free will.
Mangolad said, “I would ask him: "Is there
any meaning to all the suffering and insanity
we face everyday?
Do we matter on the grand scheme of things,
or are we just pebbles on a road?"
Suffering has no inherent meaning.
In fact, nothing does.
But the beauty of that is that you get to
choose your own meaning.
Suffering can weaken or strengthen you, it
only depends on the lessons you choose to
take from it.
And of course, you matter.
In fact, you’re made of matter, just like
everything else.
The meaning of that is up to you.
Ockinho said, “I would ask him about the
disease that SCP-049 is trying to cure.”
The Pestilence?
He always was a neat freak, that one.
I can’t say I know what he’s obsessed
with, but I can only hope that the SCP Foundation
someday cures him of his germaphobia.
Krizia said, “As much as I'd love to ask
him about other SCPs or deep existential questions,
I would rather just chill peacefully with
him while we eat hamburgers.”
That certainly sounds like a pleasant afternoon
to me.
You should swing by again sometime, and we’ll
hang out.
Especially if you buy the hamburgers.
Speedy Lurchix said, “I think my question
would be: "How can you still be so kind in
the face of the cruelty on this planet?
How come you don't become bitter or desperate
or angry?"
Nobody’s perfect, not even me.
There are certainly times that I do feel desperate,
bitter, and angry, but what’s important
to remember is that this doesn’t have to
stop you from being kind.
In a cruel world, you can choose to either
be a part of the cruelty or be one of the
brave people standing against it.
Don’t feel bad for being angry - let it
pass, pick yourself back up, and carry on
with a smile.
Ken V said, “I would ask him if there is
any SCP that he fears and/or is unwilling
to approach for any particular reason.”
There’s no SCP I won’t approach, but there
are definitely some I don’t like having
in my company.
Have you seen that slimy old man from cell
106?
Incredibly unpleasant fellow.
Antonio Ricardo Moncada Osorio said, “Can
I have a big chocolate bar?”
That’s the question I would ask before probably
thinking up something existential.”
Well, that all depends on your answer to my
next question: What’s your favorite kind
of chocolate?
Daniel Flores said, “Ever since I read about
him, I actually have always wanted to sit
and play chess with him.
No better practice than GOD.”
Well, you know what they say: Failure is the
best teacher.
And if you play chess with me, you’re sure
to receive it.
Certain Words said, “A simple question.
“What is my purpose?”
Just so I can rest easy, with my end destination
known.”
Your purpose is to use your enthusiasm and
your skills to make yourself happy and make
the world a better place.
How exactly you do that is up to you, kid.
Good luck.
Christina Jones said, "How can I live forever?"
Then I would spend the rest of our day talking
about distant galaxies and theoretical physics.”
You don’t want to live forever, Christina.
Life seems awfully short to happy people because
time flies when you’re having fun.
Conversely, you won’t find anything duller
than eternity.
However, I’ll definitely take you up on
the distant galaxies and theoretical physics.
LizzyLizENDton said, “Honestly I would just
ask “God” why he let the world go to hell.
I’m a Christian and I know God believes
in free will and letting the world do it’s
own thing but sometimes I really wonder why
He would let some of the bad happen to good
people, or happen in general.”
It’s a tragedy, really, the Problem of Evil.
Why do the good suffer while the bad prosper?
Why does cruelty exist?
Why are some fortunate and others seem doomed
from birth?
Evil is the dark residue of free will, the
ability for one to choose their path in life.
It hurts, and my heart aches for its victims,
but without choice, there would be no evil
and no good.
You’d cease to even be human, and I could
never do that to you.
Royal Frostie said, “I would ask him on
a date.
Having the ultimate SCP boyfriend.”
I’m flattered by the sentiment, but I see
you all as my children, so I’d hate to make
it weird.
El-Squishi said, “I'd want to ask him simply,
if I'm doing okay so far in life.
Oh, and ask if he has any good recipes, I
bet he does!”
You’re doing just fine.
And as long as you keep love in your heart,
and do everything you do with the goal of
bettering this world for yourself and others,
you’ll continue to do splendidly.
And yes, I know many good recipes.
I owe it to my voracious reading of Anthony
Bourdain’s books, me-rest-his-soul.
Gilda said, "God, why am I so deeply miserable
and unable to enjoy or do anything of importance
anymore?"
You might have depression.
Speak to some friends and loved ones about
this, and see a therapist if possible.
I love you, and you’re not alone.
Just keep going and I believe in you.
Merdop said, “With him being the all powerful
creator of the universe, I would of course
ask him “What’s the deal with airline
food?”
The altitude, high decibel level, and stale
air of a plane environment weaken your ability
to register salty and sweet tastes, causing
food consumed on a plane to appear more bland
and flavorless than food consumed while on
the ground.
Hope that clears it up for you, my child.
PyroTechy said, “I'd ask to be granted his
powers for a day, just to see from his perspective,
though I might be terminated after…”
There’s a delightful Jim Carrey film called
Bruce Almighty about why this desire isn’t
what it’s cracked up to be.
I can safely say that Morgan Freeman also
does a wonderful job representing yours truly.
Alexander Berry said, "Is my fate already
determined or am I able to choose mine?"
It’s as determined as you want it to be,
Alexander.
If you give yourself in and refuse to make
your own choices, then your fate ceases to
be yours to control.
But if you choose, and fight for your choice,
then your fate is all your own.
Decade Gaming said, “I would tell him to
give me infinite pizza.”
That may be a waste of my divine powers, when
SCP-458, the Never-Ending Pizza Box, exists.
The Gaming Bear said, “I would ask where
you could find the best hamburger.”
There are plenty of decent places to get a
hamburger on this fine earth, but personally,
I’m a fan of Five Guys.
Game Falor said, “Does Satan exist?”
Satan?
In the sense of a being who exists to tempt
the weaker members of mankind to evil and
corruption?
Let me tell you, my child: Those people don’t
need the help.
Henry Galley said, “I have a question for
God: WHY!?”
I’m afraid that’s one you’re going to
need to figure out yourself.
Thank you for all the questions, they’ve
given me a lot to ponder.
Take it from your creator: Life is a lot more
interesting when you’re curious, so never
let the world beat that out of you.
Little disclaimer from the Foundation here:
Whether this particular anomaly is actually
God himself, or simply a very powerful reality
warper, it’s a distinction we’re not fully
comfortable making.
Perhaps taking his words with a little pinch
of salt...
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“SCP-049 - What Actually is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”,
and keep an eye on our community tab for more
chances to take part in a video like this
one!